so where we left off we had this this
canister or because it had a closed top
and a vacuum above the fluid and the
fluid on top had a hole I'm using a big
the big marker right now with a fluid on
top in an area of a1 and I poked a
little hole with it with a super small
area a2 and I said the area of a - it's
so small it's one one thousandth of area
one and then we used the the continuity
equation we said well the the velocity
the rate at which the surface is moving
up here that's v1 times area one right
times the whole surface area of the
liquid has to be equal to the output
velocity which we're trying to figure
out as a function of everything else
times this output area and then we say
well I don't remember let's see I made a
mistake so I'm I don't know if I did
this in the last video or I did this in
my mistake video but anyway so we know
that the V the initial the this top
velocity times this top area is equal to
the output velocity times instead of
writing area to we could write area one
over a thousand right we could write
area one over a thousand and we would
still have the area one here and then I
don't I you can get rid of the area one
on both sides and then you're saying
that the output velocity is equal to
essentially or sorry the velocity up
here is equal to the rate at which the
top of the the surface moves down is
equal to one one thousandth of the
velocity of the liquid spurting out of
this little hole so now with that we
actually have the three variables for
kind of the right hand side or sorry the
left hand side of Bernoulli's equation
and what are the variables on the left
hand side well what is the pressure at
this point where we have a hole well and
this is an important thing when we talk
about you know Bernoulli's let me
rewrite Bernoulli's equation it's p1
plus rho rho g h1 plus
ro v1 squared over two is equal to
pressure two plus Rho G H two plus Rho
v2 squared over two we figured out all
of these terms so now let's figure out
the things that we have to input here so
what is the pressure at point two and
this is the important thing you might
want to say and this was my initial
reaction too and that's why I made a
mistake is that oh well what's the
pressure at this depth in the fluid and
that's not what Bernoulli's equation is
telling us the Bernoulli's equation is
telling us actually what is the external
pressure at that hole right what how
much how much it when we did the
derivation we were saying how much work
this was kind of the work term although
we played around with a little bit right
but if we look at at the water that's
burning out of the hole it's not doing
any work because it it's not it's not
actually exerting force against anything
so it's not actually doing work so when
we think about the pressure the output
pressure it's not the pressure at that
depth of the fluid you should think of
it as the pressure at the hole the
external pressure at the hole and in
this case there is no external pressure
at the hole if there was let's say let's
say that if we if we close the hole then
at that point sure the pressure would be
the pressure that's being exerted by the
outside of the canister to contain the
water in which case we would end up with
no velocity the water wouldn't sprint
anywhere but now we're saying the
external pressure zero that's what the
hole essentially creates so we're going
to say that p2 is zero so this is zero
so this pressure was zero because we're
in a vacuum and then this and then P 2
is also zero so though both of these are
zero remember that's kind of the
external pressure it's the pressure P 1
is the pressure external pressure to the
input to the pipe and you can kind of
view this as a pipe right I could redraw
that that Cup is kind of like this well
I could redraw it as a pipe like that
looks like
well I actually know the let me undo
that that has a big hole on the top and
it goes down some level to a super small
hole like that and so and this would be
a vacuum and that the fluid is just
going in and spurting out at this end
right so anyway the pressure going into
the pipe is zero and we said since we
put a hole the pressure coming out of
the pipe is zero so we're doing no work
and what is this term well this was this
was the potential energy term and we
said that H 1 is equal to H is equal to
we're saying that this is zero height so
now this simplifies to Rho times gravity
times h plus Rho times V 1 squared well
V 1 we said is equal to this so Rho over
2 times V 2 over a thousand squared all
right I just substituted V 2 over a
thousand for V 1 that equals the
pressure at the hole the external
pressure at the hole which is zero plus
what is H 2 well this is H 2 right here
which we said is zero we determined that
the hole was poked at height zero so
this is also zero so that equals
essentially this kinetic energy like
term it's not exactly kinetic energy its
Rho times V squared - B squared divided
by 2 now one thing that we can
immediately see is that we have all
these rows on both sides equations so we
can divide both sides by Rho we get rid
of all of those and then we can multiply
both sides of the equation by 2 and we
get 2 G H is equal to sorry Plus this
term V squared V 2 squared over what's a
thousand squared over 1 million over 1
million and that is equal to V 2 squared
now we could do a you know we could do
the exact thing we could subtract one
over a million v2 squared from both
sides and we would get you know point
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine v2
squared but let's just say for the sake
of simplicity or let's say if you know
if this wasn't a thousand let's say this
was a million so we you know this the
surface area is a much bigger we see
that this term becomes very very very
small and if if that whole is one
millionth of the surface area then it
becomes really insignificant so we can
ignore this this this term at because it
just makes things complicated and we're
assuming this is a really really large
number that this whole is much smaller
than that then then the surface area of
the fluid and we you know this is like
poking a hole in Hoover Dam right Hoover
Dam is backing up this huge lake and you
poke a hole in it so that hole is going
to be this very small fraction of the
surface area of the fluid and you can
only make this assumption when it is
when that output hole is much smaller
than the input hole but with that said
what is the output velocity well the
velocity is going to just take the
square root of both sides this is the
square root of sorry - gh so that is the
output velocity and what is the amount
of what is the amount of liquid that
flows out per second well we figure that
out already it's it's you know kind of
like a column of fluid that comes out so
per second the length of the column of
fluid will be the velocity times time
and then the the cross section of that
column is equal to the output area so if
I wanted to know the flow coming out it
would be the flow coming out or the flux
coming out would be equal to the out the
holes area times the holes the output
velocity and that would equal the area
times the square root of 2gh and we
could use that to actually solve
problems in the future yeah but if we
had actual numbers anyway I only have a
minute and a half left so I'll see you
in the next video